[Music]
as far as we know medieval England was
never invaded by ice zombies or
terrorized by dragons but it was shaken
by a power struggle between two noble
families spanning generations and
involving a massive cast of characters
with complex motives and shifting
loyalties if that sounds familiar it's
because the historical conflicts known
as the Wars of the Roses served as the
basis for much of the drama in Game of
Thrones the real-life seeds of war were
sown by the death of King Edward the
third in 1377 Edwards oldest son had
died before his father but his
ten-year-old son Richard the second
succeeded to the throne ahead of Edwards
three surviving sons this skipping of an
entire generation left lingering claims
to the throne among their various
offspring particularly the Lancaster's
descended from Edwards third son and the
York's descended from his fourth son the
name of the ensuing wars comes from the
symbols associated with the two families
the White Rose of York and the red rose
of Lancaster
the Lancaster's first gained the throne
when Richard the second was deposed by
his cousin Henry the fourth in 1399
despite sporadic unrest there rain
remains secure until 1422 when henry v
death in a millet
campaign left an infant Henry the sixth
as teeny weak willed and dominated by
advisers Henry was eventually convinced
to marry Margaret of Anjou to gain
French support Margaret was beautiful
ambitious and ruthless in persecuting
any threat to her power and she
distrusted Richard of York most of all
York had been the King's close advisor
and loyal general but was increasingly
sidelined by the Queen who promoted her
favorite supporters like the Earl's of
Suffolk and Somerset York's criticism of
their inept handling of the war against
France led to his exclusion from court
and transferring to Ireland meanwhile
mounting military failures and corrupt
rule by Margaret and her allies caused
widespread discontent and in the midst
of this chaos Richard of York returned
with an army to arrest Somerset and
reform the court initially unsuccessful
he soon got his chance when he was
appointed protector of the realm
after Henry suffered a mental breakdown
however less than a year later Henry
suddenly recovered and the Queen
convinced him to reverse York's reforms
York fled and raised an army once more
though he was unable to directly seize
the throne he managed to be reinstated
as protector and have himself and his
heirs designated to succeed
but instead of a crown York's head
acquired a pipe after he was killed in
battle with the Queen's loyalists his
young son took up the claim and was
crowned Edward the fourth Edward enjoyed
great military success against the
Lancaster's Henry was captured while
Margaret fled into exile with their
reportedly cruel son Edward of
Westminster but the newly crowned King
made a tragic political mistake by
backing out of his arranged marriage
with a French princess to secretly marry
the widow of a minor noble this
alienated his most powerful ally the
Earl of Warwick Warwick allied with the
Lancaster's turned Edwards jealous
younger brother George against him and
even briefly managed to restore Henry as
king but it didn't last
Edward recaptured the throne the
Lancaster Prince was killed in bow and
Henry himself died in captivity not long
after the rest of Edward the fourth
sreyas peaceful but upon his death in
1483 the bloodshed resumed though his
12-year old son was due to succeed him
Edward's younger brother Richard the
third declared his nephews illegitimate
due to their father's secret marriage
he assumed the Regency himself and threw
the boys in prison though no one knows
what ultimately became of them after a
while the princes disappeared and
Richards powers seemed secure but his
downfall would come only two years later
from across the Narrow Sea of the
English Channel Henry Tudor was a direct
descendant of the first Duke of
Lancaster raised in exile after his
father's death in a previous rebellion
with Richard the thirds power grabbed
causing a split in New York faction
Henry won support for his royal claim
raising an army in France he crossed the
channel in 1485 and quickly defeated
Richard's forces and by marrying
Elizabeth of York elder sister of that
disappeared princes the newly crowned
Henry the seventh joins the two roses
finally ended nearly a century of war we
often think of historical wars as
decisive conflicts with clearly defined
winners and losers but the Wars of the
Roses like a fiction they inspired show
us that victories can be uncertain
alliances unstable and even the power of
Kings as fleeting as
[Music]